Esther do you get scared um when it's
just you in the house no I don't I get
lonely Esther's not afraid of ghosts
right and it's a good like dose of Youth
or something like I love when I'm re
anything that brings me back to a young
moment I'm just like dinner like
whatever I want dinner to be I don't
know I'm not Consulting anyone and Dave
would if he was here he'd be like you
never consult me and we never have to do
it together but that's it just helped
I did I did send you a picture of my
dinner last night because you were like
hey
um asking about that recipe I talked
about I'm with a chicken and you called
it a hot girl food a healthy hot girl
it's not a hot girl it's healthy hot
girl healthy hot girl but I okay she's
making her own like chicken stews with
ginger and carrots and cabbage get on
board [__] I know so you know it's the
easiest thing to make too it's you just
get the pot you just put them in I know
I want I'm like ready it does it for you
can we we gotta talk about it about what
my titties I'm wearing a corset it was
oh that's what it is it's very hard to
get it's so funny that you waited for
Dave to not be there to have to put a
course on
is right
this show is sponsored by betterhelp if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule visit
betterhealth.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help he lp.com trash Tuesday hi
slugs I'm doing stand up and I'm coming
to Miami and Atlanta and Raleigh get
tickets at Esther andice.com hey
sluggies I am on the road join the
welcome to Annie wood tour having such a
good time please come see me draw your
abs on or I will draw them on with
Sharpie after the show at the meet and
greet
um I will be in Greensboro North
Carolina this weekend I will then be in
Canada in April Raleigh North Carolina
in May Salt Lake City in June and
Calgary in August I also have a lot more
dates being added so go to
annieleterman.com shows to check it out
and also every Thursday is Annie wood my
show that you can listen to or watch on
YouTube
it's my little solo baby please come
party I'll see you guys there
foreign
this [__] in like two weeks to be like
because I'm on a plan I don't we're
talking about eating like I I plan out
all my meals now which is cool I like
cook them ahead of time don't you think
about food yes well it's not hard stuff
okay I know we always make plans and all
I know but I just want to say that I
would really love to have like some sort
of cooking tutorial hang out if that's
ever enough I'll show you what I eat but
it'll be different for you it's like on
your that's okay specific body no I want
to copy exactly what you have because
it's from my weight
I'm getting skinnier
I'm happy um but I don't want people you
know I love to down that banana I like
to deep the banana I like to swallow it
whole I like to regurgitate and eat it
again but I just am like playing and
it's not the sound
I love eating that banana I love that
banana break I like to chew that banana
I swallow that banana I ran out I don't
I don't want it to sound eating disorder
it's just I want to plan I'm so excited
everyone has an eating disorder this is
America we we're we were teen girls at
once America this could be Australia
don't listen to this [__] okay I um
this is why I love my trainer he all he
tells me like all the guidance he gives
me
like for eating is hey eat eat today get
your carbs in eat eat he's always
reminding me to eat and I love that
because he's like this is gonna be hard
eat carbs today the carbs carbs which is
very against what I learned growing up
with the whole Atkins the keto craze he
was like no I want you to be strong in
the gym eat your carbs I love him yeah
always but I never I was a lean monster
you know what I mean back then so it's
like wait is it safe to say that every
diet is all just like marketing and fake
like yeah all the fads when you say
Atkins I'm just like that was so and now
you know the brand you know the logo
yeah and snack well that man did drop
dead and they did cover that up did he
really oh can you wait what's the story
of Atkins then maybe we'll go to a
Reddit post about it they're like
oopsies so our leader died
um
Atkins fell and hit his head oh okay
yeah yeah he fell on a sidewalk massive
heart attack from only eating cream
cheese and beef
my mom and I did because my mom and I
would do all like the fat diet me too
cute though but I mean I would start
measuring out you know I know the exact
stats of ketchup like because I would
count the sugars and ketchup because
with Atkins your first couple weeks
you'd have to be under 20 grams of carbs
right see how your brains are [__] up
from this lifestyle do you guys oh I
know victims we're all victims I know
none of us are victims we're strong
powerful women we've got to rise above
these victim things guys and remember
with Atkins you couldn't eat fruit all
your veggies had to be high fiber why am
I eating cream they'd be like more cream
cheese like more cream cheese right my
body is like maybe one schmear a month
like I don't
Philadelphia but my body's not like give
me some cream cheese what about like the
like way back before Atkins I'm sorry
did you guys not ever buy a box of those
[__] delicious snack walls cookies
the foamy chocolate covered soft cookies
and you think you can eat the whole box
and that's completely fake and
meaningless oh how about when I went I
think I must have mentioned this one
when I went vegan for like a week and I
was like oh vegan sweets and I forgot
it's like still sugar Falls for it oh I
was I was just the the biggest I'd ever
been in my life I can tell you my really
unhealthy girl rituals is if I knew I
was to party in Vegas in a few days I
would load up on the mag citrate
um bottles and laxatives and then I
would take um two days before I would
lose like six pounds in water weight
feel really busy
trying to diarrhea from that diarrhea
and then I would do Senna tea because I
would watch my aunties be really hard
corn to sanity and I think that's what
threw me into like early colitis because
it put me in such a state of
inflammation constantly it's so painful
one time I was having a sleepover with a
Victoria's Secret model and I went
through her stuff when she was asleep
and she had mag07 have you ever heard of
that it's like what it it's basically
like helps you [__] it's like magnesium
and oxygen I thought that was magnesium
it's probably the same it probably has
the same laxative effect like I cannot I
would have to like she said allocate
like a certain for legal reasons a
certain window of time I'd be like okay
if I take this today this is Victoria's
Secret model she's talking about no
Esther's gotten her way in actually
someone else in the uh comedy podcast
Universe was also there
Rick Glassman anyway was he going
through her stuff too no that's actually
like troubling no there's like a boy
actually I kicked him out maybe more of
a predator
but we did [__] like that I would be
like oh I have to take my magsa trait
I'm 48 hours from my Vegas trip and now
I have to stay home for six hours
because I'll just be [__] for six
hours it is like it's like the type of
the direction you swing with an eating
disorder is like really like how
controlled you like it's all control
issues but it's like there's the other
end which I was more of a binge eater
like I had trouble restricting me too I
had full and I was binge eating over
exercising it all like yeah they all you
could do the whole rounds the whole
marathon of yes disordered that was the
biggest takeaway when I went to an
eating disorder treatment program was
like oh duh when you try to restrict and
starve yourself the pendulum will always
swing the other way and then you'll
binge eat so if you just feed yourself
like a human a human being you care for
you're not going to be starving and you
you're much less likely to bend and
um there is something I think a little
bit more Sinister that's happening I'm
seeing a lot in like my friend groups in
La which is they are claiming allergies
they don't have allergies too because
and I see it I'm like oh I can't have
that or I can't have that and they'll
give like I'm allergic to apples I'm
allergic to this and I've seen them eat
this in like loads before and I'm like
oof like you're starting to do what I
used to do which is try to justify why
I'm not eating something because you're
ashamed to just say hey like I'm
actually disordered as [__] I see that a
lot and I was gluten-free I am you know
and I'm like gluten-free why it's like
is it no just because I choose it and
some people really are Gluten Sensitive
but a lot of people that I know are not
because I see them down full gluten
things that they're not aware of and
they're perfectly [__] fine
but you know what I mean right I know
yeah of course I everyone a lot of
people do but you aren't that toilet
maybe there's some diarrhea there might
be some squirty diarrhea you don't know
about it and it's like you start to
replace one with the other so it's like
you get rid of oh I'm not purging
anymore I must be improving but then
you're now restricting another kind of
food and then another kind of food you
just do the whole I've always struggled
with your um sensitivity to Dairy
because it's always just made me feel
like how could this be how could someone
I connect so closely with actually get
hurt by Dairy I'm better now though I
took so much time off that I can have it
I don't have it like a lot of it okay
because I think I just like stopped
having too much of a taste for it but
yeah I let myself have dairy now I just
before I would like diarrhea I also had
with eggs I would throw up sometimes if
I ate eggs I would just be puking which
sucks it's so embarrassing because
you're I'm never eating eggs like at a
regular I'm always like it's like three
in the morning when having fun with
people mashed potatoes or I'm having not
mashed potatoes like um eggs like gravy
and this yeah and eggs and [__] I'm like
a late night breakfast [__] supposed to
be like having fun afternoon on the road
with dance soda once we're like just
having this great time and I'm like see
you guys in a sec I'm like [__] the girl
like puking just oh [__] it's almost
like my body was like you're an
alcoholic Drunk [__] this is the time
period you would be throwing up at but
so I had to stop eating eggs for like
three years and then I like started
putting them back in and I've been fine
but he's taking me like excruciating
pain and then I would throw up and
diarrhea
there was times where I was like smoking
weed and I was like
you know every day and I was like can
weed make you diarrhea and I was like
it's eggs
but yeah I've been like putting it back
in I have like Greek yogurt and stuff
and I just try to listen to my body and
I I really do try not to do the [__]
eating disorder stuff because I think
what that was is just trying to have
someone else's body
yeah you know like not like listening to
my own yeah like what is my body but I'm
excited to be like
um
you know I remember when I was in high
school I when I first started seeing my
boyfriend like we would hang out and we
would have so much fun and like I
wouldn't have an appetite you know
because I would like just be like on the
high hanging out with a guy I liked and
then I would come home late at night and
I think this is like how my binge eating
habit started and I would be so hungry
that I would like sit in the basement
and eat like four bowls of cereal and I
was like yeah I don't know what my point
is with that I remember just happy times
on my boyfriend my high school
boyfriend's waterbed and he lived in the
basement and then going upstairs and
just eating so because we were so high
we're smoking out of like the two liter
bong
and going upstairs and just eating so
many uh ice cream sandwiches
like ice cream sandwiches are like in my
heart that's why I'm like those two
things though just straight up cereal
bowls and bowls and ice cream sandwiches
you're really speaking to me right now
that's what a great bingy food like
where you've been like magic spoon Lucky
Charms in the basement watching Madonna
music videos you know what's up buddy
Todd eats like this still he does yes
Todd eats like a like a 14 year old wait
so does Dave yeah it's like a boy thing
I think it's like they're self-soothing
they need their cereal to like remember
cartoons no I think it's no it's not
even that it's like that they're just
normal and healthy and never had to like
banish those foods from their lives like
we had to but the thing about that's why
intuitive eating so good because but it
was funny I remember listening to an
intuitive eating book on
audio with my parents when we were
driving back from Boston and we stopped
we stopped at a grocery store and we
were like oh we're allowed to eat these
things it was one of the best memories
that I had with my parents we binge ate
so much [__] together it's just funny my
dad I think that's another thing too
where it's like I don't get mad at
myself too much when I do bingy because
it like is like fun times with my dad I
had where I'm like this can't be bad if
we were like laughing yeah I was tied to
a good memory my parents were always
like fighting and throwing things down
the garbage disposal and like laughing
and just pouring soap on each other's
cake like it was always very funny that
is that makes me want to be adopted it
was really funny I like my sort of
eating disorder adjacent happy memory is
like going to Walgreens with my dad and
like obviously sometimes we would get
candy like a lot of the time but
sometimes we would go and we'd like
stand in the candy aisle and be like
okay which one would you get and he like
no I'll do a Twix well no I'll do a sour
patch we'll know that's our way oh my
God you window shopped yeah yeah wait
guys I'm on mushrooms I forgot to tell
you that right now very little bit
don't make it taste good I'll be like on
the wall like am I on the ceiling I
think it's like she had like a couple of
the chocolate it was nothing yeah no not
a cup I don't even think it would be a
couple what they're very tall when did
you take it
a couple hours ago because I don't want
to say this out loud because I don't
think it's real I don't want to let it
be real but I've been having like little
tiny inklings of my cluster headaches a
little little little so I'm like I just
want to start doing that's why I'm like
laughing I'm like micro dose like isn't
this funny
um just a little little but I think it's
not happening because I've done so much
work structurally on my body and with
breath work and stuff and tape that
[__] mouth shut at night do you
really do I haven't done it in a while
but I have to again because I was
reading like some of it's like connected
to sleep apnea they just can't figure
out what clostridics are but a lot of
the studies are like and they have a
whole thing called cluster Busters which
is a whole
website and chat thread for us cluster
Busters sound like they taste really
good you can get them at Dairy I want a
cluster bust in your mouth
wait that's a that's a good name for a
hemorrhoid cream cluster Buster because
they come in little grape clusters
didn't you guys ever get a peanut buster
parfait at Dairy Queen
Dairy Queen came a little late in the
Philippines
listen Dairy Queen was very early in my
life yeah but I I'm like I I'm loyal to
Butterfingers and mint chocolate chip
blizzards yeah yeah that's what it was
okay fair I I had it we're gonna I was
very loyal with Oreo Blizzards for a
long time too I had my thing I said why
would we switch but then I started
honestly when we started this podcast it
was just around that time I was like I'm
gonna start getting things I don't
usually get and I've been really
exploring the world now guys but so I
just have been taking it just the second
time taking them just because
the way that I've read that it works and
you know I've only skimmed so who knows
and I usually have cholesterol eggs when
it happens I can't look at the screen
but um is that if you start with micro
dosing mushrooms you can really knock it
out but if you start by using the meds
that the meds block whatever it is that
the mushrooms will do so I'm gonna just
do this what is the meds like they have
there's so many different ones that they
give and none of them really work I mean
it's really crazy but you can do like a
steroid pack which will give you like
Shadow headaches where it's like not the
full pain but I know the exact length of
how long they would be
how are you feeling on the microdose
like I'm feeling great do you feel like
I wouldn't I would say like whenever I
do it and I feel it a little it's like a
little happy and a little more awake
yeah I feel like oh I might need that
though very small but I'll bring them
next time I forgot I was gonna bring the
bag and be like anyone in
but just a little bit because I have
like a scale and I was like weighing it
and someone had said like a gram I'm
like I'm not taking a gram of [__]
mushrooms it's too much I don't want to
be like thinking about life and death
and time and yeah the Continuum space
time we can go there if that's what you
you need today yeah I'll go I'll go
there next time I'll take a macro
something really bad happened to me
um I believe
over and over again what doctor did what
your kids away if you're at home put
your kids to sleep now you guys did it
involve you not being able to shave your
life trigger a warning this involves
theft and fish you got I had somebody
like mail me
um jars of like 10 fit like fish that he
had just caught that was like a really
prized fish and it was FedEx to me and
it said it was dropped to my front door
the new house uh yes and um I believe I
looked all my neighbors porches and
nothing and so someone stole my fish
I thought you were saying a stalker left
fish oh
it'd be fine 100. so sort of what she
said too yes a mysterious man with
prized fish I told you we weren't
supposed to read your poem you got
but this is a really sad thing for me
like I was really looking forward to
receiving like I know but you know what
though you diarrhea or something I know
it's not as good as like the from a
mystery man but we can always get you
some fish wife I was very yes wasn't
like are we seriously talking about Tin
Fish I'm not bringing up our girl oh
that's right Caroline yes this is what
you were being disloyal and the lord
well this is not tinned fish this is
here's the thing is he never fishing
again can he not do it again he's
fishing again tomorrow and so but this
was like a really really good fish you
guys well I told you guys how that
happened to me where my my okay Todd's
this is so hard to explain Todd's
sister-in-law's brother oh yes he's an
artist and he sent me these prints and
I got stolen easy so he's gonna send him
again but at this point it is like
should we just call it a yeah I take my
money the [__] well it's like my hope
is that someone enjoyed it you know and
someone ate it
but it's it's a very great thing to
steal it's food it's delicious like and
you see it and you're like oh that's
good
do you have a camera ring camera I I do
but it wasn't on it was not at that time
anyways okay so this weekend sorry
that's a good euphemism for being
molested too your fish was stolen
my fish keeps getting stolen no just
whatever [__] fish also packages have
been showing up again to me it's weird
from where things have been stolen and
then reappeared recently it's very weird
and also I have like a locker system at
my apartment and I will go get a locker
room to be empty and I'll be like why is
this Locker empty and then they'll be
like oh we put it in the wrong Locker
we'll resend it and then it won't ever
be sent again and go what was this thing
there's just mystery things you know I
wake up in the middle of the night and
just order order oh that's right that's
right
which I love I love middle of the night
behaviors I've been sure
yeah
um so this weekend I went on this random
Saturday morning Beverly Hills mansion
Garden Tour it was me and a bunch of old
people
um but it was this woman Virginia
Robinson and I guess she's like one of
the original like basically founders of
Beverly Hills like this amazing
sprawling mansion and
um one thing that I didn't know is that
the reason why a lot of movie stars like
inhabited
um Beverly Hills is because Glendale and
Pasadena and all the other neighboring
towns wouldn't let they didn't want
movie stars to live there because it was
like still Vaudeville times kind of and
so it's like
those places down to are not filled with
celebrities and like rich people because
they look down on it isn't that crazy
like Beverly Hills was just like liberal
and that's why they're now they're not
now it's all old people but I don't know
I was really fascinated by that yeah and
then comedy is the lowest rung of
celebrity too yes yeah we're the joke of
the joke but
um Pasadena has a very because I that
was where I lived when I first came to
America I was passing another High
School in Pasadena
um but Pasadena has a and Altadena has a
very rich weird history that's where
guys like who you know would experiment
with like LSD or like L Ron Hubbards
from there or that's where they had
their little cult meetings out to dinner
um but Pasadena is very much its own
thing and I can see it is but it's very
like old old like Rich money like old
old money and I can see how they would
look down at Beverly Hills but like I
would never look for a home in Beverly
Hills it's so not hip or cool it's like
you're all your neighbors would be I
don't know I don't see it as like a cool
place to live you know about how there's
Cults and stuff there is because old
money like when people see old money
they go oh how do I get some of that old
money better start a Coke
these old rich people and to give me
their money this money that's just been
passed down to them how do we
recirculate all that rich people money I
think that's a thing that people outside
about they do not realize about Beverly
Hills because I know when I thought of
it I was like oh my God all the rich
young hot people Paris Hilton whatever
but since I've lived here like and me
and Benji we used to hang out at his
parents office in Beverly Hills and we
would always joke like that's how I can
be the youngest hottest woman in La is
by being in Beverly Hills because
everyone is elderly yeah it's yeah it's
an it's been geriatrically community at
this point yeah Betty White was living
there yeah but you know what it's all
about now it's the Hidden Hills baby oh
yeah gotta go behind gated community
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because we
are always growing and changing
I don't know about you guys but I wake
up a new person every single day and
that's probably a mental illness in it I
was gonna just say it's diagnosable
like I am every minute I'm alive I'm
embarrassed of everything I did up until
that minute so getting and then now you
need to go to therapy so you can let
that go yes
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and your understanding
because sometimes we don't know what we
want we don't know why we react the way
that we do until we talk things through
and With Better Health it's really as
easy as filling out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge
everyone's doing therapy now everyone's
getting better you don't want to be the
one not getting better and it's this is
just the easy way to do it you don't
have to wait in line you don't have to
find parking no that's the thing in
traffic it's just this is the way to
just get in you know that's why I'm so
jealous of people who are in their 20s
now that have access to this because
that was such a thing getting in my way
like finding the therapy is finding the
office something that's close with
parking like the fact that this is all
done online conveniently is so huge yeah
I mean I mine were always like the
College counselors and you're like
you're the same person that's seeing
everyone your son's in my math class I
saw you at the Christmas party why were
you Santa why was I sitting in your lap
discover your discover your potential
with better help visit betterhealth.com
trash Tuesday today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash
trash Tuesday
wait can we just how did the house tour
happen I am weird now I like this
doesn't seem weird oh okay it is right
it seems on brand oh I will do this this
is something I would we could have
vlogged I saw it on a tick tock and was
like I need to go there the fact that
your life is like a Choose Your Own
Adventure Tick Tock it is it really is
Annie you just nailed it the fans wanted
they think we don't have chemistry
anymore because I don't have Tick Tock I
don't know what the [__] she's talking
about ever
we the other thing on the tour was so
weird so basically like the It was
obviously a very old like nice house and
the doors I don't know if you've ever
seen this like those doors where they're
double wide not double doors but it's a
single door that's really wide oh I like
that and yeah and she's like does anyone
know why the doors are so wide and like
me and all the 90 year olds were like no
and she's like it's because they it was
it's for so they could bring the coffins
in I was like what did you know this
like basically in the old days they
would you would have your funeral like
in your own home so your coffin would
literally come to your house and
everyone would come and like you knew
this yeah it's awake
yeah that's how we do it in the
Philippines we bring you you do the Wake
the coffin is in the home yeah what do
you mean that's not normal maybe that's
our next live stream is our funerals oh
how cute I love that okay we're doing it
I promise yes you like mushrooms you're
dead I'm gonna take advantage of you
while you're in a good mood I'm in a
good mood I'm always in a good mood pull
your pants down
pull your pants down and close your eyes
since my home downgrade so
um since I've moved out I no longer have
a bidet and it no longer self flushes so
I've had to relearn how to flush toilets
and it's been a struggle you guys
usually it's like I just you know do my
business get up and walk away and then
now I have to do all the things like
I've forgotten to do which is like look
and then flush
okay everything because there's nobody
um I'm like cold because my old um
bathroom had the the seat warmer I know
it has a massage everything you know so
now it's like okay first treat yourself
one get yourself a new twizzy but also
who care leave it you're asserting your
dominance over your new space leave that
piss and [__] in that toilet yeah let
the place know it's yours
I do that and I always don't flush when
I first go into a hotel room to assort
my dominant and Bobby admitted on
tigerbelly recently that he's been
actively marking me what um and that
every time he knows I'm on a phone with
a gentleman caller that he he'd
intentionally barges through barges into
my space to say hey babe are you gonna
make me that pasta
like he's always and he says that it's
his way of basically saying I'm allowing
you to talk to other boys but they
better know that Papa
is number one okay first of all I think
every single girl should have a
recording of a man saying hey babe are
you making me that pasta so they can
play it in the background of calls to
intimidate guys
but they know what Bobby looks like so
then they're like I'm not so
intimidating and so that was basically
he was saying he was just like I know
these guys are taller better looking
than me so he's like this is my only way
but I eat parts are way better than that
yeah and basically it's like this is my
only way to assert dominance and I find
it so funny like I every time he does it
I'm like I have tears in my eyes I think
it's so funny but um I don't know what
do you guys think about marking people
do you guys do the same in your own way
you know what Dave will often bring this
up like literally over the last 10 years
I'm always a little bit more
affectionate in public he's always like
you're you're always touching me in
public and it's never conscious I'm
never like actively doing it I'm never
thinking about it and I think it I like
suddenly I'm like oh is that what it is
am I just like showing everyone that
like my man yeah I don't know I wouldn't
think it was kind of odd if someone hit
on him
I don't mind that you know I don't
either you know me
oh my God that's that has happened once
and it did not go well
I would tell how did it go I just I
wasn't cool all right
well it's who you were it's cool I
wasn't cool like how I wanna know there
was a girl who was just really flirty
with him was she hot
no
I would just say that that it was
someone
and I felt like it it just went you know
my flag went off and I was it was just
not cool how did you react
started a big fight
what did you say I can't I can't I can't
but that's enough I was just like that
[__] [__] likes you dude do you want
better more views I was like that girl
likes you stay the [__] away from me
I don't know why they were like wait
Esther this is so relatable what are you
talking about this isn't this is so
relatable especially when someone says
oh no no no they were just being this
way and you just know it in your head
I'm like no yeah I know this person
likes you and it's it's one of these
things where like when if a partner were
to say the same thing to me like hey
that dude [__] likes you I never try
to say now I'm like yeah he probably
does no you're probably right you just
give in I give in because it's like I
don't know but also like you're sensing
something so I'm gonna acknowledge that
and like you shift that to them yeah and
I'd be like no I get that and I then
they're like they're trying to keep
something from me but me and Dave I
think are so not used to that that I
really do believe because I relate to
him that he did not believe that that
person was into it but didn't you feel
kind of excited when you did it
I think now I can look back and be like
oh that's cool that [__] wanted my man
but in the moment no he must have I bet
you there's a little part of him that
was like excited that you were like
fighting for him Annie and that's where
you're very very wrong Dave is not like
and I'm like that and you're like that
and I [__] get it not Dave
he did not like it at all and let's just
say I was not invited back to that job
because of this is what I did
well it can stop I was after a job
I was at his work well if you think
about it it's like well because here's
okay here's where that makes sense and
it's good you said that because it's a
it's a relationship that exists
somewhere else
right but you were a good girl for not
being causing the scene with her yeah
and you went home and then he was like
all right now you're gonna be weird in
my work so you can't come yeah yeah
thank you thank you Sam thank you so
much thank you
[Music]
so this thing just happened to me after
um when Bobby and I broke up and there
was like a lot of speculation about like
our relationship why it ended blah blah
blah people had their theories and and
a friend of mine contacted me straight
up friend just a friend
and basically said hey my ex-girlfriend
um sent me this thing on Reddit
basically saying that
um you and I are a thing on the side and
I'm like what he was like why is my name
being dragged into this I'm like I am so
[__] sorry like apologies whatever
anyways his ex-girlfriend he says is
like kind of like a crazy person like
why was she deep in the [__] why was
she going through my [__] anyways right
and um
and basically people like thought that
he was a guy that I was like hooking up
with and I really like thoroughly
apologized
but then
she wasn't wrong because something about
what she said planted a [__] seed in
my head
and about sorry Scotty the seed wasn't
planted a whole like a whole like 10
months after like Bobby and I like broke
up and everything was settled I was like
why am I thinking of this person and
then I ended up like hooking up with him
oh I want to know about this I'm getting
horny I know but what I'm saying is that
like there is all there is a thing about
like you're gonna end up together and I
guess that his ex-girlfriend was like I
know you I know you I know you're
[__] [__] kalila on the side and
he was like what the [__] but it also
planted a seed in his head he was like
wait why aren't I [__] awesome you're
being a crazy [__] so now I don't need
to like you no longer she's no longer a
person right she's falsely accusing him
something and not letting him tell her
the truth yeah that's no longer a person
that's like trustworthy for him either
so then he's like I don't have to be
loyal because everyone together anymore
they were dating 10 years ago so he was
like what the [__] [__] I don't even
talk to you anymore wait really she
didn't they weren't they were not
friends they were not speaking he
blocked her so she emailed him a Reddit
thread basically saying I know you're
[__] Cole Island he was like what in
the [__] is going on this is just like
what is on Reddit what my life would be
like if my high school ex had things
about him on Reddit
yeah and so I think that she was keeping
tabs on him so deeply that it ended up
she ended up finding out that I was his
friend but she's kind of a witch because
she I think planted two seeds and then
we ended up like hooking up she sounds
like a creative genius I think so thank
you whoever you are manifesting kind of
finder taking pictures of Esther and
listen
put your coffee out
she's on my team now I've recruited her
do you feel like a team what do you mean
do you feel like you have like a team of
people
um are you building one kinda I feel
like that all like yes but always in my
life like since I was like five I've had
a team
how about you of friends or just people
who like that you work with that you
well I guess you kind of have a team
yeah yeah yeah I like working in a team
it makes me feel like yeah I had that on
my last Ayahuasca thing I was like I
love my team I have like a good team I
like all the people I'm meeting I'm like
yeah I was never made to be like I was a
swimmers which is an individual Sport
and I hated it it's just you yourself
your own failure no one can console you
you beat yourself up because this is you
in the water you never did relay relay
was always fun for me relay was like oh
yeah I get to actually enjoy and play
around swimming have you been swimming
no because of my shoulder my [__]
shoulders guys come on Frozen that was
like so I was originally on imp did
improv in college and like at i o in
Chicago and stuff and then when I moved
to LA that's what I wanted to do but I
had no friends I didn't know anyone
that's why I like stand-up made so much
sense because I'm like oh my God you
don't need anyone else but now I'm like
oh I missed the fun of like a team and
making are we starting an improv trip
I did that it's called bloodbath
um no I had an improv team with Rick
Glassman Aristotle Melissa via Senor but
how long ago like 10 times ago yeah a
long time ago Sandy Danto was on it guys
if we start doing live stuff improv
improv you could improv really you think
that I have straight men okay yeah I
can't CSN [__] that's all you got to do
oh yes Sam the [__] out of every every
single scene is like about us being
molested
Esther's like always behind the gate
wait childhood trauma again
um I told you what happened when I
started doing improv right the opposite
thing okay so I when I first wanted to
do comedy I wanted to do stand up but
I had moved back to Philadelphia I
didn't like know
how to do it like I didn't know about
mics I didn't know so I looked up a
comedy class thinking that it was going
to be a stand-up class did I tell you
this no and it was an improv class the
Philadelphia improv theater fit and I uh
I wanted to join it but I was like so
nervous I had no friends or anything so
my dad was like I'll join it with you oh
that's so cute I did improv with my dad
that's insane did he crush it he was
good but he ended up quitting because he
was like knew I really wanted to do it
and he's like I know that you're not
being like your full self on there but
he also was like so sexual all the time
I was like oh yeah that's right like why
is like now it's like you're trying to
get the girl to put her tongue in her
ear or something my dad's like me doing
everyone
just your average James Franco class
oh my god when me and Benji like found
out we were gonna do a loan together and
we both were like oh we wanna like
improv a lot and we had not done improv
in a while so we were like let's sign up
for UCB 101.
which we thought like that would be a
good idea it was not it was so awkward
we were like 10 years older than
everyone else there and everyone
afterwards was like wow you guys are
really good and we literally didn't go
to a second class well 101 the thing
that's embarrassed the thing that's
crazy about 101 is it's like any 101 is
just like a guy that works at an office
whose friends yes and he's like okay
I'll go take this so it's like everyone
it's not the way to prepare for like
being in a show it was so awkward but
very funny but improv is actually so fun
and I think doing it first because I
never would have done it like if I knew
thank God first of all I didn't just
start with the stand-up class I I know
it's worked for a lot of people I know
that um what's his name Jim Gaffigan
started in oh he did stand up class I
think um I would have done a stand-up
class but I was dating Tony and he was
like you can't do a class no I know it's
like I mean the person I am now would be
like Annie what are you thinking improv
but it was so helpful it really helped
me with my like stage presence and all
that stuff but I was so like tight and
then I ended up dating my improv teacher
oh lucky it was actually he was so mean
to being glad reenactment remember I
like it really was like what's that
right we just reenact our trouble but he
didn't yeah he didn't he didn't assault
me yeah
he never jerked off so it's like I did
make him like can you just drug off
right here nope that was too high is
there a world where if you have did
reenact that like what would that be
meaningful to you at all if like Todd
jerked off on your leg you know I think
I would be not I don't know that it
would trigger me but I never know with
my because I've done like so much work
on myself but it's like sometimes it's
just like a trigger comes out of nowhere
you're like oh my I can't believe that's
[__] triggering me and then you're
like all right I have to figure out what
triggered me there like what that was
because it's something that I haven't
well a real trigger for me is when like
I go from zero to 60 and I don't know
how I got there why I'm feeling already
that [__] like hyped and like it's
almost like are you able to trace it
back
in it takes a while because you have to
get back to like a regular yeah like I'm
all of them fully heightened already so
it's gonna take a minute I'm so clouded
my vision I have no sense of like
reality in that moment yeah I'm just
like fully physically in fight or flight
I have a question for you guys like when
you said you don't know like sometimes
you'll get triggered and you'll be like
oh I keep like that was so Random
do you still judge yourself when you're
triggered like do you get upset about it
or are you able to be like Oh I'm no
that's the thing I'm working like oh I
noticed that upset me or do you get or
do you still be have to stop yourself
from beating yourself up I I get
conscious of when I'm beating myself up
so it's like a little bit the same thing
right but so it's like I start to beat
myself up and then I'm like like love
yourself like this you're just
re I like not like you don't like it's
not like excusing the behavior because
obviously if I flip out in public or if
I yell at someone that's abusive you
know it's like not okay but it's like
you know clean it up as much as I can
and then have Grace for myself where
it's like
where Grace so silly that's such a great
word yeah but it is you know just be
like all right like I you know I forgive
people when they yell at me you know
like I go okay that was yeah their thing
or whatever so why would I not do that
for myself same same
yeah it's so annoying when you realize
like every issue you have in life is
just you I know it's so awkward but it's
you know my favorite feeling is is when
you come around to that full circle of
like accountability where I'm like I
[__] up there and you say it out loud
and then you like I apologize like I
just snapped at somebody last week for
no [__] reason I didn't know that I
was close to my period because it came
like eight days ago I'll let you know
yeah but I didn't know right so I was
like I'm everyone around us always knows
before us last to know
the only one not crying but I'm also
crying oh my God and I fully rip this
person's head off
um and I was saying things like you're
so [__] judgy am I just being like
I'm like a judge yeah [__] judgy and
he was being so calm and really and
afterwards like I was just again I beat
myself up I'm like why the [__] did I
act like that and I came back around out
and I was like look bad attitude I've
had a bad [__] attitude I am so sorry
like I'm so ashamed of myself like I but
that feeling alone of being like I'm I
just take a hundred percent
accountability is so like releasing do
you guys okay I saw this on a Reddit
thread and I totally disagreed with
everyone
[Laughter]
does knowing that other people can hear
you having sex make you want to have sex
more because for me the answer is [__]
no sex is like so private I don't want
anyone hearing or knowing anything about
it even Dave
but like so many people were like oh
yeah that makes it so hard if people can
hear follow-up do you does he hearing
other people have sex turn you on
no it makes me feel left out oh my God
you don't want to get foam out of your
neighbors well basically it's like
you're not natural like exhibitionist
but I am kind of maybe you're a voyeur
because I'm a voyeur hearing people have
sex really turns me on I like it it
doesn't turn me off would you ever strip
but would you ever like do like a a
session at a strip club because I know
you kind of get like you just are so
like you come alive when you're dancing
and Performing for people but would you
ever do it naked like probably yeah yeah
so just throw a dick in that
do you like would you here's the thing I
was a drunk so I was like sucking dicks
in bathrooms and [__] if you knew your
neighbors could hear you not my
neighbors I wouldn't want that I would
be quiet but that's hot to be quiet it's
like reminds me of like [__] when
your parents are there you know you want
to be like not in the room but I I'm
kind of a teenager it's like fun to be
like I don't get off on the idea of
being heard I get off on the idea of
people possibly hearing me and me having
to keep it down like in your parents
room so like if you're like like if I
you know if I'm sharing like a space and
I know someone's in like the bedroom
over or whatever and my partner kind of
just being like shut the [__] up is
really hot to me so yeah
why can't they just don't you wake my
[__] parents up you [__] [__]
[__]
um but yeah like just being loud just
being an exhibitionist like that does
not get me off yeah yeah because I think
that that point it's a little
performative like I'm too focused on the
way I feel and being really present yeah
and do you really like to get like talk
show too talking because I always have
I've had boyfriends in my life that do
that we might have talked about this on
here but I'm always like no no I don't I
love sweetness I love when I know you
hate this I don't know if it's you or
you like I love the the phrase like
making love I like when dudes say
they're gonna make love to me I don't I
love it I know that most people hate it
and it's such an old person fake like
where I'm like ew don't try to like it's
like they're like reading me no it's
like fashion yeah exactly and I think I
want to make love to my girl like if a
guy says that to me like I'm so just
like oh yeah I feel really soft and like
in the old-fashioned like make it I like
when guys are like I want a nut ew
adorable I
like trash waterbed [__] but I do like
when you're [__] I'm about to nut I'm
like okay
like you are
oh their chains are like hitting me in
the face
you're a girl I can see myself in your
grill I definitely like conversation
white boy bro
oh my God I do like what my favorite
thing is watching guys like when they're
about to come like seeing that extra
weird scooting they do is really cute
me too actually I don't want to talk
about can I show you what it looks like
okay because it's just this God's
pre-come face is very cute it's very
like this right
but when they're close it becomes a
really awkward scoot it's not cute they
don't look cute but I know it you know
what I mean so they kind of do the you
know what I mean what I mean right yes
yeah because it's like they're out of
control they're out of control
you have to pretend like I know what
you're talking about because a guy's
never come with me but yeah they don't
want you to have it they're all
gatekeeping
no one will let me have their sperm it's
so sad that's why they use condoms so
you can't have it it's not because
they're afraid of you
like she's not getting this they have
someone take it away they're like take
this away quick
I didn't want her to look at
look at it Esther you've never been
nutted inside of no I have oh but I'm
just I was not for cubes it was
no I definitely have well
um
yeah I've had to go
there's a little tiny elephant in the
room oh yeah I forgot about that there's
a little peanut sized elephant in the
room you know it depends there's certain
boyfriends where it's like you got to be
on the pill for them because that's
where they need to go and there's others
where like that's they don't need to go
there the Phil is such more [__] what I
know it feels like fake why would you
say something that does this to us oh
the pill oh I like listen when I tell
you I've never been suicidal I mean I've
never in my life considered once killing
myself except I was on one drug and it
wasn't that I wanted I was like punching
I was so mad I was so self-angry and it
was all this pill
birth control or no no
Prozac now that was birth control I
can't remember which one it was maybe
Ortho tries yeah birth control [__] me
up what did make my skin look really
clear though but it made me like I've
never seen you with bad skin thank you
you gotta get the the high dose
glutathione it only lasts for your face
is like really great what is that also I
get facials where they do
um lymphatic draining oh that sounds
like it feels really good yeah but it
also like it glows you up I yeah face
like I always think I want a facial and
then I get one and I'm like this is too
much calm
can I have it and they're wiping it
clicking it off
I see her you keep it in the side of
your mouth like in your like when they
check to see if you took your pills and
I'm insane asylum wait Esther should we
pull or lift up your tongue
okay so I do know how to identify
healthy and unhealthy sperm I can
identify a broken neck and a sperm
whether or not it swims well yeah
because I've been on sperm Tick Tock
maybe you were a broken neck sperm and
that's why you have a fake neck injury
oh my God hey get space I think it is
like a stress thing
my neck injury why is nervous it is
better now
do you guys like where your birthday
falls in the calendar yeah you do why
like what's your case for it this is
like fun outside parties I was always up
we always and it's like with my brother
but I think my like luckiest thing in
the world is that I was a twin born at
midnight so then I had like
individuality too that is so crazy I had
like a friend like someone with me but
we weren't like I'm suspicious I think
that how could that be it's true six
minutes apart at midnight
wow it was 11 58 and I was uh 1204. I've
realized so my birthday is March 2nd and
I think it's like
it's good because
I feel like I got most of the year at
that age and then the New Year comes and
then I'm like okay I got one about like
two more months in to like Savor this
age and this year of my life but the
only thing is because it comes right at
the beginning of March and February is
always a short month it's like everyone
always forgets it
me coming up with a reason why people
forget my birthday
a leaf in there but it's just that
nobody likes me it's just you get 16
candled every [__] she doesn't know
what that means I don't they okay the
premises into 16 Handles is is that a
cake place it's a frozen yogurt shop in
Palestina makes sense but yeah no she
like wakes up and it's her 16th birthday
and she's like oh it's gonna be so
annoying everyone's gonna be like it's
your birthday it's your brother and that
friend forgets her birthday
everyone totally forgets her birthday is
that your like dream or nightmare
that's a good question because it could
be a good like thing to hold on over
people I like that I genuinely don't
like holidays or birthdays so an ideal
birthday is like no one really knows and
it's not awkward because of pressure
yeah well how why do you feel pressure
I feel embarrassed when it's my birthday
I had that when I was like four so I can
relate to it but
no I did feel I used to feel that way
where I was like wait Esther how did
your parents celebrate your birthday
growing up
I don't remember
I know like when I was a teen I would
have like sleepover parties obviously
um Rick was that all of them which is so
weird
sleepover parties yeah
you didn't have sleepover parties or
everything yeah wait took over parties
with teachers and our doctors do you
like where your birthday falls on the
calendar no mine was a uh pretty shitty
for me growing up because November 1st
is the Day of the Dead
um in the Philippines and so the whole
the upside is the whole week was a
holiday like a Federal holiday the
downside is that we always spent it in
the cemetery
um for you know like welcome to the
world this is where you'll end up yeah
basically watching my uncles I get drunk
over like my deceased like family
members like tombstones gravestone so it
was never about me
um and this was usually a time like when
typhoon season would really roll around
so like electricity electricity was
usually cut off we'd be like have like
candle at home for like you're like oh
my God can I just have flights for my
birthday and then coming to America
everyone's so focused on Halloween that
it's sort of just like but and also the
time change over here what made it
really bad for me is that this is when
the clocks fall back
right around my birthday and it's always
when my depression hits wait your
birthday answer is so traumatic like
they're so you're still going like I'm
like whoa yeah a lot yeah let's wrap it
up
Hey Oh wrong question what about now as
an adult like do you like that day or
what's your relationship with the day
um the same the same as it's ever been
that's why I try to go hard on my
birthday so it's like kind of like not
forgotten I love my birthday it's so fun
it took me a sec but it's fun yeah yeah
but here's what I lost in my birthday
because it's July 20th I never got to
like have custody School in school yeah
I never got like School attention or
anything but
it was fun but summer birthday is the
best I think it's fun yeah and now it's
cool too because I always try to like
have my birthday with my family yeah
isn't it July birthday kind of like the
dream because then it's like you're
halfway point till Christmas you get
some presents like it's spread out
evenly that's a good point yeah I can't
even imagine
[Music]
for me it's kind of annoying in
relationships because it's so mine is so
close to Valentine's Day that I'm like
you gotta both still count you know well
you give me one sperm then
have you guys um read the um book by
Malcolm Gladwell um outliers yeah yeah
like birthdays matter I read it like I
read it birthdays can can be a really
big Advantage depends on when what yeah
yeah like depends what um month of the
year you're born especially in sports
especially in sports so it's like I
think that people should be well that'd
be weird right if that means like your
age you are when you go into a season
yeah what grade you're in like yeah yeah
because it can really determine even how
you stack yourself up against your peers
like in that same grade or in that same
age division in sports because you're
like am I bad or am I just young right
am I really good or am I just older and
more developed because there is such a
big jump in your physical development at
that age like 11 12 13 8 nine you know
so I mean having been in sports like as
long as I was like I definitely felt it
yeah I was um
we were at first we were the youngest
ones and then we got held back and then
we were the oldest one
in kindergarten yeah why
well my mom told me she goes don't tell
anyone
um but I guess at first it was my
brother had learning disabilities and
they didn't want to separate us so they
were going to have me go to first grade
but they decided to keep us both back
and then like second grade they're like
oh this [__] can't read they're like
[Applause]
look at it sounded out
and here we are now
I could still be in second grade if
Freedom was the thing I could still be
in second grade wait how fun does that
sound to go back to second grade I want
to so bad she hangs she makes one movie
with Adam Sandler
wait what was that one better watches
movies [__] I've seen Billy Madison
it's so good do you know remember the
premise it's like his grandmother this
is my explained premises of movie
episode
Yeah well yeah where he like goes back
yeah that is funny to like it's cute
yeah and it's like kind of like the
dream to just finally crush it well
would you do I was thinking I could do
like I could definitely like if I went
to high school now it'd be [__] so
awesome yeah doesn't everyone think
about that all the way would you do a
Never Been Kissed yes sich yes I'm
trying to not [__] the teacher this time
well let's I didn't [__] him he just on
me I didn't like it I was not consenting
but then it's also sad because then when
you're actually around people who are 16
it's like
oh my God I'm so old and then like that
part of you that ignites where you're
like that little party that wants to
impress the six you know what is the
saddest it's there's not a sadder part
of a person's personality or body the
part that wants to impress a teenager
that's why some of these boys
you gotta that you gotta release that
part of you okay
he's uh not on them please
but it's like Bonnie's daughter's I
think she's 15 now she might be 16. but
I I mean I just had to be like why am I
trying to get this like why am I
pandering to this child she's awesome
she's cool she don't need some friend of
her mom's to be like
yeah I have to say I don't Pander to my
niece and she's 15 she's pretty cool
[Laughter]
panderings stealing her clothes she's
taller than you so much taller than me
huge her feet yeah she's way bigger than
me her room is so cool though how old is
she I think she's 15. oh you're so funny
bless you know the better
for everyone's safety
my nieces are coming oh that's right
they're coming they're surprising me
because I would surprise them yeah
they're excited it's so cute they want
to go on I was like should I take them
on a mansion tour they want to do like
Hollywood things so how cute is that I'm
gonna take them to Rodeo Drive
on one of the tours up to the like
celebrity houses the map of this I've
done that that's it's so fun it's gonna
be so cute I'll do the TMZ tour and then
we're going to Universal and stuff oh
cute
I love that I'm so excited I have to
like work on my acting skills like oh my
God you're here
oh
you guys this has been so much fun no uh
why are you sexual right now flirting
with you guys oh
um slugs thank you so much for being
here with us we love you you're our best
friends forever and we'll see you next
week with a brand new episode
bye bye bye
[Music]
thank you